It's already difficult for introverts to find their niche in a world that predominantly
values extroverted tendencies. As a result, introverts needs are often overlooked,
including the way they function in relationships. Here are 10 things you must consider if you're dating an introvert
Number one: Hold meaningful conversations
Introverts look for depth in a partner, someone who can keep up with them when they talk about
possibilities in theories. If there's one thing they never get tired of, it's the mere entertainment of ideas
Hoping to discuss open-ended questions, instead of ones which end in one-word answers
Enlighten them with your knowledge and wisdom. After all, intelligence is sexy, classy, and timeless
Number two: Spend time in less stimulating environments
Introverts are sensitive to external surroundings
Instead of going to social parties, they prefer hanging out at small gatherings in quiet places
It's not really about the setting, but the company they choose to spend their time with
Number three: Take it slow
A slow and steady pace wins the race to an introverts heart. They're careful about who they let in
They like to gather as much information as possible, before they display more affection towards people
While their self-control might make them less exciting on the surface,
There's so much more they can offer in a relationship that isn't based solely on impulse
So don't take it the wrong way if they don't display a lot of affection on the first date
Number four: Be sensitive
Introverts tend to internalize a lot, so they're prone to bottling things up inside
They need someone who can sense and consider their feelings, because they don't enjoy starting conflicts
That's not to say that they're necessarily afraid of it, but they're more careful about what battles to fight
Number five: Provide mental support
Introverts are prone to overthinking and overanalyzing
It's hard for them to stay in the present when their minds are filled with thoughts and concerns
They don't mean to do it, and it might create a distance and
misunderstandings as a result. Try not to take it too personally
Chances are, they're probably ruminating over on what move to make next,
because they care about how your relationship is growing, or they may have a lot of other things going on in their lives
Play the best friend role and provide support. It'll help them ease up, and they'll appreciate you more than ever
Number six: Read between the lines
Introverts are very subtle, so they're not usually outwardly flirtatious
The way they communicate is very nuanced. Pay close attention to what they say, and how they say it too.
Sometimes, even the smallest phrases can have large meanings behind them
Number seven: Respect their space.
While they may like you, Introverts also have a need for space
They need to go off on their own to recharge, so it's important not to be overbearing or suffocating
That would only add more to their stress levels, and may cause them to retreat within their shelves even more
Number eight: Spend quality time together
It's not about the amount of activities you guys end up doing, but the way you two interact with each other
Spending quality time with an Introvert is crucial,
Although it may seem as if they go off on their own, at the end of the day,
They still crave meaningful human interaction.
Learning to make the most out of time spent together, creates a strong bonding experience
Number nine: Fully accept them.
We live in a culture that's obsessed with self-improvement, always striving to be better
As Introverts living in an extroverted world, ever since a young age,
They're seen as individuals who can be molded and conditioned to love being in the spotlight
because "better" somehow translates to "extraversion", which is pretty dehumanizing
When they're trying to build and maintain stable relationships, they don't want to be seen as potential projects to be fixed
Instead, we assure them, and be sure to express that you love them for who they are
Number ten: Don't assume
Always ask questions and communicate with Introverts. They may be slow to reveal things,
as communicating doesn't come easily to them, and their silence can often be misinterpreted
That's not to say they're incapable of expressing their thoughts,
but a lot of potential conflict can be avoided, as long as you encourage them to converse with you
What are your experiences with dating an Introvert?
Are you also an Introvert?
Do you agree? Leave your thoughts in the comments below
If you enjoyed this video, be sure to visit our website and other social media for more content, and if you'd like to support us,
please check out our new Patreon account or grab a digital magazine from our shop.
Links will be in the description below. Thanks for watching!